souk petite localité à 45 minutes de
victoria est ici derrière ces murs on
fabrique un des meilleurs gêne au monde
john kaiser qui a été chef cuisinier
pendant 23 ans avant de ré orienter sa
carrière vers la production artisanale
d'eau de vie talent indéniable puisque
son jean a d'abord été reconnu le
meilleur au canada et voilà que jeudi
dernier un appel téléphonique de londres
confirme que son si ça aide de jane est
consacrée meilleure au monde dans la
catégorie jean contemporain jason
fabrique son jeans avec amour mais il
n'aurait jamais imaginé avoir une telle
reconnaissance et rapidement puisque la
distillerie existe depuis seulement
quatre en infusion macération avec des
épices et des herbes jackson prépare de
la vodka du jean et parfois du whisky
dans cet atelier son épouse hélène
s'occupe des ventes et du marketing pour
l'instant la distribution se fait en
colombie britannique en alberta et au
manitoba
mais cette reconnaissance arrive à un
bon moment l'entreprise pourrait bientôt
distribué en france et au japon
quant à la recette et bien pas de secret
les ingrédients sont en démonstration
dans le magasin coriandre pétales de
roses citron orange lavande et cette
algue cultiver tout près dans le détroit
de juan de fuca cette algue selon jason
de nos jeans les saveurs du terroir
jane d'apps qui les clients en
redemandent
c'est la meilleure vodka que je n'ai
jamais goûté s'exclame ce client fort de
cette reconnaissance
la demande est en hausse à la
distillerie sheringham plus de 200
bouteilles ont été mises en boîte
lors de notre passage sur les tablettes
du magasin les médailles s'accumulent
celle du meilleur jean au monde devrait
arriver de londres sous peu il c'est
éric tremblay radio-canada à souk près
de victoria